icarus
like dips down on his girlfriend
basically because ajax told him
the truth he felt like every boyfriend
that betrayed you like i was so doubt
about it
smooth talking jerk the direct quote
from my friend i saw it with she turned
to me and goes of course it was the
white man
hello everyone and welcome back to
another episode of the after show today
we're going to be breaking down marvel's
eternals taking you through the major
events of the film while deep diving
into the details and answering some of
your burning questions left after you've
seen the film
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can't protect
[Music]
any of them and along with us today we
have two incredible guests first we have
brian tong he's a video host and creator
and i just saw his new laptop ladies and
gentlemen very jealous very jealous
alongside him today we also have nora
dominic she's a tv editor over at
buzzfeed holding it down for our east
coast friends hey norah hey brian how
you all doing hi what up jacqueline this
is the deal the film has a 49
rotten tomato meter score which makes it
the first and only mcu film to ever be
rotten the critics consensus says it's
an ambitious superhero epic that soars
as often as it strains eternals takes
the mcu into intriguing and occasionally
confounding new directions so brian i'll
start with you
the score says this but do you really
think this is the worst entry in the mcu
it is not it's absolutely not for me i
think
you thought i was going to go there
jacqueline that's what i'm here for um i
really do it is not you know i i
actually was really surprised i thought
the critics would lean more positively
towards it because it was more of a
different style of film and it was
really more of you know a kind of a mix
of what we've seen from the mcu and more
of that independent chloe zhao art house
film kind of fused together and it
worked sometimes and sometimes it didn't
but i thought the critics were going to
enjoy it even maybe more than the fans
who might be used to this marvel formula
and being delivered a specific type of
brand of movie that's why i enjoyed it
i'm not saying it's the best movie but
definitely wasn't the worst movie either
yeah which i didn't mention this but it
has an 80
audience score and the box office is
already 71 million domestically and
162 million worldwide so
nora bringing it to you i mean were you
surprised by this reception um you know
where do you think it ranks as far as
the mcu
yeah i definitely wouldn't rank it in my
bottom of my personal list of mcu movies
i would kind of probably put it for my
own personal ranking towards like the
middle kind of like what brian said like
it really kind of it broke the mold of
the mcu like cookie cutter you know
movie and i really enjoyed that and i
loved what chloe was able to do with it
um yeah it lagged in some spots but i
think that was just kind of the nature
of having to introduce
so many new pieces to an mcu movie um so
yeah i definitely wouldn't rank it in
the bottom um and i did really enjoy it
i was a bit surprised by this score that
being said i agree with everyone with
what they said it's not a perfect film
but when you look at the mcu and to me
there are several entries that i would
put
definitely
not necessarily lower but saying that
the eternal score does not make it worse
than those
i was very uh
very surprised about that a lot of
people in the reviews question was chloe
zhao the right person for this because
it's essentially her trying to insert
her style into the mcu formula and where
it works it works but where it doesn't
it really doesn't do you guys feel she
was the right director for this and do
you think she'll be back i love what she
was able to do it was so expansive and
just visually unlike anything the mcu
has done and it was beautifully directed
so i'm ride or die chloe i think she was
so great in this and i would love to see
her come back too
i mean i'm smiling when i'm hearing
everything that nora said and i'm buying
all of that you know we want to see we
want to see different films quite
honestly i'm
look we love the mcu we all do and it
was like i said earlier it was kind of
surprising that the critics
were almost turned away by how different
this film was i i thought that they
would really embrace it so
i love what's chloe's doing you know in
an interesting way this movie does feel
pretty self-contained and i could see
them
maybe i'm not saying they will maybe not
pursue a sequel to eternals but use
these eternal characters in other films
as this whole phase 4 develops and maybe
that's a reason why chloe zhao might not
return until there is a need for an
eternals 2 where there may not be
because
the the tapestry and the scope of what's
happening is they really use this movie
to build a foundation of what's
happening cosmically in the in the mcu
um
i don't know if we'll see her back but i
want her back so it'll be interesting to
see how that all plays out
i actually do think we're gonna get to
see an eternals too because i think the
thing they're gonna rely on is the thing
that other studios uh when they've had
lackluster i would say sort of uh
critical receptions is look at the box
office i mean
this film has already cleared 161
million it's probably going on to clear
probably you know maybe half a billion
dollars at the box office in the middle
of a pandemic still where box office
receipts are not near what they were
pre-pandemic levels i think it's a win i
i think like you know they'll take their
lumps on the critical reception maybe
try to make the next one better the one
thing that's a bright spot
both with their pockets and with their
voices on rotten tomatoes we have an 80
critic score and 71 million domestically
um our audience consensus says it's a
different type of marvel movie but the
eternal still contains all the action
humor and heart that fans are looking
for i don't know why there is this
divide can you guys maybe point to
what the audience is not as wrapped up
in maybe what they leaned on more i
would say than the critics in this one
ryan what what would you say
i think what the audience has shown that
the mcu
if you're building on the story of
whatever phase four is leading us to
people don't want to be left out of it
right we've invested
10 years and what's this 23rd movie i
believe um
into this 26 sorry into this franchise
and they haven't steered us wrong yet
and i don't even think this was stirring
us wrong this opens up the entire cosmic
universe in new ways so i think that's
why the fans are so happy about it i
think the more interesting thing has to
do with expectations and anticipation
yeah i think that the audience was just
anticipating this
with the ferocity that
critics maybe didn't
um because we were still going about our
normal sort of like talking about the
season type thing
but i do think when you talk about the
critics
there was i would say some things
internally that they were dealing with
most namely she's coming off a best
director and best picture win and i just
don't think you can ignore
that that put her in a separate category
of reception that's my take i don't
think that the biases have anything to
do with chloe zhao as a female director
or action genre
or any of that
but
oscar winning director do we have
different expectations i'd say that's
fair nor what about you
yeah i think expectations for chloe like
you said were very high especially you
come off of like you're an oscar winner
you
gave us this movie that was critically
so renowned and then you go to a marvel
movie and you're trying to break the
mold and i think what brian kind of
touched upon is as marvel fans we want
to see the next movie because we want to
be part of the conversation and we want
to know that puzzle piece that's going
to lead us forward so i think i think
eternals and even like one division is a
great example of it broke the mold and
fans didn't care because they loved the
characters and they loved seeing
something different and i think eternals
is in that same vein where we were all
really excited to see this cast these
characters and we wanted to see where
this epic is going to take us next so i
think we enjoyed the ride and we were
able to deal with the slower parts of
the movie the more expositional parts of
the movie because it got us to
post-credit scenes that are really
important it got us to an ending it got
us to an ending where like we loved the
characters by the end um and we got to
see what happened with them so yeah i
think it was a little bit more of the
mcu fans kind of knew that this is going
to lead us somewhere bigger and it's
also going to be a very standalone film
and we were okay with that
yeah again i i don't i wish i could give
you a definitive answer but i just can't
reconcile my idea
that
the mcu
sorry that that chloe jiaoz version of
the eternals ranks alongside some of the
more mixed to poor
completely aggressive you know what i
mean like
yeah that doesn't make any sense to me
that's me personal
but we shall see i'm gonna go ahead and
jump into the more movie breakdown first
but let me go ahead and set the stage uh
again
big spoiler warning this is the final
one we're gonna be breaking down very
specific plot details so if you haven't
seen eternals you should have already
tuned out but especially tune out now so
breaking it down the eternals opens up
and we find ourselves following 10
warriors
as they sort of live on earth trying to
protect it from deviance which is these
sort of like demon-like creatures they
come to find out through the course of
this film that they've been waiting for
the emergence and they think that means
that they're going to get to go on to
the next planet they've been on the
planet for literally eons
you know hundreds of years before
a man started documenting time and it
turns out in sort of the plot twist of
the film that they are actually only
there to watch humanity eventually be
destroyed so that the celestial being
born from the center of the planet that
they sort of see these planets for this
purpose
and uh you sort of you know the eternals
at that point decide that they do want
to save earth and so they band together
to try to stop the emergence so in case
you couldn't tell by what i said this is
a very large scale scope of the film
both in time
and as far as where it goes across the
globe so i just have to ask you do you
think
it was successful
in the sense that it added so much more
but then was still able to sort of like
merge into the current mcu
and keep us interested in these new
characters nor i'll start with you
yeah i think it like i said earlier it's
a very standalone film and i almost i
wonder
if like any of my friends that haven't
seen all of the mcu movies how much they
would enjoy this movie simply because it
is so standalone but as an mcu fan like
you said it really does open the world
so much wider um and we're adding these
characters that are going to become
vastly important to the mcu going
forward and hopefully interact with
characters we've like come to know and
love brian just jumping ahead a little
bit
you know these 10 people that we get is
sort of introduced to they all have
various powers who is your favorite
because the film sort of opens up with
us learning who all of these characters
are and um their abilities and really in
that opening sequence you really kind of
figure out exactly you know again what
they have to offer but also the dynamic
they have with each other yeah i'm gonna
say even though i'm a sucker for
speedsters but i thought the way that
they used the effects with makari like
it felt different than what we've seen
from speedsters before so from a
superpower standpoint i loved makari but
from you know this is a chloe zhao film
and
you know i really loved fastosa's
character i thought there was a lot of
there's you know when they talk the part
of the reason why this movie might have
felt longer in exposition we had to
actually really learn to care about each
of these 10 eternals but but if you are
invested in that which i think many
people were
it really was rewarding as it built up
to the final one because as we see fasos
journey how he feels responsible for you
know hiroshima with the technology that
he helped advance he gives up on
humanity
he has he finds a partner in life they
have a young child and that gives him
hope back into you back to humanity like
that i thought that was just kind of
amazing art that didn't take
you know that that might be an arc we
might see in a single character for a
whole movie we know that we had to kind
of go through so many but i really loved
fast those and then i was hoping like oh
is he just a tech guy or does he
actually have powers and then when we
get to like the throwdown in the end
with icarus i'm like okay he also has
powers which are based on his brain and
his ingenuity so
i thought um
i loved those two characters but fastos
probably stood out the most for me for
his journey and and what he offered
another aspect of this one too is
the fact that there's the past into the
present so that opening scene where we
got like get all of their powers in the
past
and then nora when we jump to the
present
we get a little games of thrones up in
here
because because we have kit harington
and and he ends up being a part of this
weird sort of love story because the
thing we find out is icarus and cersei
were lovers through most of their time
as eternals but when we go into the
present which is like the first scene
after the opening kit harrington is the
one that's like romancing cersei what
did you think about his character
uh nora
i loved kit in this role too it's almost
like he's playing a less broody game
like jon snow like it's like yeah it's
very funny like it was nice to see him
not like brooding around and having a
lot of like he had the joke about the
giraffe and it was just fun to see kate
and that and i think what i loved about
you know his character is he's so
important but unless you're a massive
comic book or marvel fan you probably
just enjoyed seeing kit harrington in
this role and then you get to the post
credit scene and he's going to be
massively important and i think that was
interesting i saw it with a friend who
had really only seen like the trailers
and like richard madden is really set up
as like the lead of this movie and then
you know we really end icarus's journey
by the end and it sets up kid harrington
to be you know more important um so yeah
i definitely i'm really excited to see
where he takes his character because
it's so important and he's such a great
comic book character and i think it's
going to be great to see what he does
with it
i mean just continue with that what's
interesting too so kitty harrington's
character is um the black knight which
is a huge mcu character that they're
probably going to introduce and have his
own either television show or film and
this next stage of the mcu
but the thing i noticed with him is like
when he finds out cersei is isn't
eternal like he didn't care and at first
when i was watching the movie i was like
you know this is post blip
globe like people disappeared for five
years like people
in
this version of earth have dealt with
some really weird stuff you know
these atari's coming down from the
heavens like there's just like a lot
you know
so they are able to deal with more but
then we come to find out when we get to
the post credit the reason why he's able
to deal with it is like oh he's got his
own and he literally says he's like my
family history is complicated and i was
like oh okay
i see where we're going with this um
he's again part of this like crazy uh
love triangle one of the things that we
find out i think it's like right after
that you know icarus shows up to save
the day
and really does that like um mr steal
your girl scene
we find out you know like the details of
icarus and cersei's love story including
the first
you know
bounty cabal for sex in the mcu it's our
first sex scene
bryan what'd you think about that one
because we got to see that one like
it's like a weird setting
richard madden and gemma chair were like
in the in the audience when we saw it
i don't know it was it was there was
more movement to that sex scene like i
could see them making out with the shirt
off but there was like
some some lower some lower thrusting
going on there i mean exactly
that's it i didn't i didn't expect to
see that in them you know it wasn't even
that i had ruled it out of possibility
but it was like oh we're going here
okay right it was kind of actually
shocking to see it was
i get it like it it solidifies how deep
their connection and their romance was
um
did we need to see it maybe not but if
this is i don't think we did quite
honestly um not that i'm against like a
little love like you know and and heat
and everything but i don't know if it
acts that actually scene actually added
to the story but is if we're trying to
show that
these are heroes that participate in
human acts
i guess that is
maybe shows them to be a little more
like us because i think maybe one of the
issues if people are having problems
with connecting to the eternals is these
aren't just heroes these are kind of
like gods right they're like synthetic
gods
and i think part of that was
so much of what we've seen in the mcu is
characters that are on the ground level
that at least we can connect to in many
human ways
right out of the gates you don't feel
like this is a group of humans or have
any kind of ties to humans so
maybe that is
a way to help us feel like okay they are
more human than we appear and they
aren't just these synthetic
creations but i don't think it was
necessary
so another thing on top of
romance it's sort of like going into a
different area the one thing that the
mcu i think always kind of has is humor
and i think pretty much from when we saw
his casting we assumed this would happen
but like i think the thing i read most
was like scene stealing what'd you think
of kingo and especially camille
looking absolutely shredded in this but
still being very hilarious do you like
the costume we need to talk tell the
director i have some notes we need to
talk to you in private
oh karon he's worked with me for 50
years i trust him completely
actually when we first met he thought i
was a vampire and he tried to stake me
through the heart
i've apologized so many times not quite
enough times very close though i'll let
you know whenever camille came on i mean
it was it was fun it was awesome you
were laughing and without him
i don't know if this movie is very funny
at all quite honestly you know with him
and karoon and then karuna's kind of
like reminds me of the like the c-3po
type character he's just saying out loud
what we as the audience are seeing and
being our eyes as as that as that uh
foil so
love the two pairings of them and uh
absolutely necessary but he he crushed
it yeah especially playing off of the
other characters and he was always you
know setting up a joke or you know
really crushing a joke home and i think
it it was great for him the the you know
what the humor is actually kind of like
drier serious humor too right camille's
not like over the top you know hey no it
was like all within the tone and i think
that's actually a little harder harder
to pull off and i mean that ikea line
still hits yes
we've seen it five times
but it's still hit even in the theater
yeah oh or even the one where it's like
oh the bollywood star it's like i'm done
correcting too like that one too that
one first of all i think it hits harder
industry-wise because we all know that
dude we know that influencer that never
turns off
so
again like the dynamics the family
dynamics of everyone in here they all
bring a certain thing to it but that's
not to say that it's just straight humor
again even within the group outside of
the romance outside the humor there's
also like i think platonic love with um
gilgamesh and athena but you know that
was one of the things that was like put
forth on the character summaries was
like they had a really
deep bond
i think some people thought it would be
a romantic one but it's so different um
what did you think about that one nora
because
i think that's like the closest we've
gotten to that maybe
maybe is some
black widow hawkeye type stuff yeah
maybe i don't know what do you think
yeah i really i love a good like
platonic friendship and i think
in terms of male female like you said i
don't think we've had a lot of that in
the mcu and a lot of times it does turn
like a little romantic-y um i also think
of like you know okoye has been that
kind of in black panther as well um so
yeah i really enjoyed it i'm glad it
wasn't romantic and i think it really it
was kind of what we were saying before
where you really had to get to know
these characters so well and it was so
great and what they were able to do in
the amount of time that they had and for
characters we've never met before um so
especially like when gil dies and athena
is like heartbroken and angelina's face
and it works so well and especially at
the end when she's you know fighting the
deviant and is like trying to remember
what he's taught her i think it hit so
well because the characters were so well
plotted and because the actors were so
good at the characters they were you
know playing you know i love this new
theme that we've seen of kind of
platonic love and platonic friendship we
even saw it in shanghai
with um with uh simu and aquafina's
character and who knows maybe it
develops into something later but you
know we're i think we're all tired of
the cliche of like these people have to
end up kissing and be romantic by the
end of this film and so to see this kind
of you know you'll have like the lamb
was like oh you're in the friend zone
okay fine maybe he's in the friend zone
but also he embraced the friend zone and
didn't make it weird and awkward so
i i love i love this new exploration of
like showing how
we can have nuanced relationships
between two different sexes and i think
it sometimes makes it more powerful in
in by showing it that way and the things
that maybe can be said and can be done
or can't be said and can't be done
because it is a platonic relationship i
was going to say it's interesting
because i came in they were pushing
icarus and cersei so hard like in the
promos and i came out of this loving
makari and druid and want that
relationship that could be a romantic
relationship i would love to see i think
lauren and barry had such good chemistry
and i was just reading that chloe said
that that wasn't in the original script
like you weren't meant to be you know a
romantic relationship and she saw lauren
and barry's chemistry and knew they had
to go down that route and you know
really kind of play it up so yeah i
think it's kind of what we went back to
the found family and all of these
different pairings that just worked so
well together so it was really nice to
see you know the platonic relationship
but then also like a hint of a romantic
one for a pairing probably audiences
weren't expecting when they went into
the movie
absolutely i actually um
gonna go ahead and name drop a little i
was really blessed to moderate this
press conference for eternals and that
was the thing i asked lauren about
specifically was
their bond because i was like putting
that these two really sort of bonded
through their frustration with the
situation like lauren anything that is
not as fast as she is is going to feel
frustrating and then for druid just the
fact that he could snap his fingers and
chain and stop so
many horrible things because horrible
things live in the minds of men and he
can control that and so
yeah that that whole idea i thought was
interesting of like you know and they're
both like the rule breakers a little bit
yeah you know so so i love that with
them
bringing it back a little bit to gil and
athena though
it's funny that we all have agreed that
it's platonic love but because athena
essentially is a ptsd survivor with her
sort of like mad weary issue that's
because um we come to find out that mad
weary means that uh spoiler alert she's
she remembers what happened on the last
planet that they were on when everybody
died and then they sort of like reboot
the hard drive and they go someplace
else the feet the when any of them are
suffering from mad weary it just means
that that synthetic celestial remembers
the last time
that they uh all died and so athena has
it in this current iteration and i
really do feel like if gil and athena if
theta was in a different place maybe
that romantic love could have developed
but the fact that it didn't it's not a
circumstance of could or would but more
circumstance of like the love that can
be accepted which i also thought was
really beautiful
basically this whole idea of like the
secret of the eternals is the fact that
they are essentially gardeners of
a funeral pyre like nobody lives
they they live on these on these uh on
these worlds try to get them to a
certain level of advancement because
then that means the planet is ready for
this the celestial to break through it
and kill everyone because it needs that
energy from that advancement
and icarus
like dips down on his girlfriend
basically because ajax told him the
truth
and and he didn't want her to be as you
know heartbroken and sad as he is so he
goes and lives his lonely brooding life
leaves the love of his life
and
when ajax comes to him to be like we
need to save these people he kills her
how dare he
i know and it was one of those things
where i was like
i don't know man icarus was like
he just felt he felt like every
boyfriend that betrayed you like i was
thrown out about it
nora did you get that energy i was like
smooth talking jerk the direct quote
from my friend i saw it with it was my
second time seeing it she hadn't seen it
and she turned to me and goes of course
it was the white man
and i was like yeah like of course like
the broody icarus like of course yeah
that was the funniest though too i mean
it wasn't evil he just couldn't
couldn't adjust himself well enough to
see the bigger picture
exactly that
wow that that that that goes in a lot of
layers right there jacqueline i'm not
going to say anything i'm just going to
thank you
it's a look yeah
what about you ryan what did you what
did you take from it
well i mean i kind of saw it i saw it
coming a little bit right even before he
told camille or sorry kingo
that you're not i'm not what you think i
was already like oh man this guy's gonna
freaking screw this stuff up right like
you you could sense it right and so
quite honestly when he goes and like
gives like ajak the little push i it
didn't that part actually wasn't very
shocking to me right i feel like a lot
of times when you have the turn of
someone it is a big deal
maybe it was just me but for whatever
reason that actually wasn't as impactful
of a turn because maybe
it was too easy to see for for me i
don't know how did you guys react to
that scene like were you like oh my gosh
i was like oh i mean figures
i mean i don't want to say i was like
nora's friend but i was very much like i
don't trust this one yeah me too like i
knew that there was more villain to be
had in this story than what we saw with
the deviants
and
the thing that actually clued me in was
actually literally when they found out
ajax was dead
like icarus looks at her body and said
she was killed by deviant but like how
do you know yeah
like that just seemed a little bit like
well she wasn't technically he was she
was killed by deviants though
technically true that i'm not saying
that she wasn't but he was just too
quick to that answer for me
and yeah watch way too many like make a
choice cut scenes from video games like
that dude is always the dude that you
need to like later on it's like should
you trust warrior three no no
like it literally felt like a video game
cut scene in that moment where you're
just like
i know you're not real um but you know
it's i'm not saying that the the
plotting was like video game cutscene
just just that just that one particular
aspect yes so that brings it on like as
i sort of like poke fun at it but that
sort of brings it on to the part where i
think
for the most part a lot of people felt
the movie sort of
you know fell apart and that's the third
act look they're building towards we're
trying to stop the apocalypse this is
nothing new in the mcu
but
yeah it just that did not work for many
people uh how did you guys feel about it
i thought the end and that final battle
was the slowest part for me i think um
in terms of like before then we had had
like you know the flashbacks the past
and the present we were learning about
these characters and then it felt almost
kind of rushed stopping this you know
big thing that was occurring um so i
understand where the criticism for that
third act comes from because i kind of
felt it a little too and it was almost
as if like like i missed kingo not being
there but i understood his choice and
then it all got wrapped up so fast and
then it was the end of the movie um
so i so i think definitely it was and
not even like it was bad it was just
like a pacing issue where it was like
all of a sudden we hit the end of the
movie this big thing has to happen and
now we have to wrap it up and send them
off to do the next thing we're
eventually going to see them do um so
that was my thought on it for whatever
reason
i was like just waiting for some i'm not
even the guy that has to see the action
scene but i just felt like
yo these are eternals i need to see them
use their abilities like to its fullest
in some level of a battle so i just know
how how do they even function you know
at a high stakes scale
battle when all the chips are on the
table and so i remember even whispering
to my girlfriend when i watch i'm like
oh this is good now
i remember
like oh here we're finally getting to
the climax of the fight so yeah i think
pacing completely left my brain to be
honest with you i was like okay here we
go now everything that we've invested in
these characters is gonna pay off and so
i actually really like that part and
normally i'm not that guy but uh i don't
know maybe i think the the pacing was
the whole exploration of these
characters i needed to see something
like that and so you know it delivered
for me personally
i'm gonna be like real just whatever i
don't know if i agreed with the whole
kingdom disappearing thing
like yeah
that was i was waiting for him to come
back
i don't know if that was like
party like of me of being like oh but
he's gonna show back up but it's kind of
like ryan said it's like i wanted to see
the action and i wanted to see his
powers so like even the best part of
that whole fight was like when they were
on the beach i'll fight nicoras makari's
doing the awesome running and like all
of that stuff like that was great so
yeah i thought the same way jacqueline i
thought he was gonna show back up i
guess for me if i had to say it i think
it's probably one of those additional
photography we just had to make the
story work situations you know what i
mean like they go back like every movie
now which when these become news stories
it drives me insane every movie over 100
million dollars has a section of the
budget cordoned off for quote-unquote
additional photography meaning that they
know at this point that no movie of that
scale is going to get to the end of the
shooting schedule without them having to
come back at some point
after they've done the strung out which
is the first edit
and before they finalize the film and
send it off to cgi where they may need
to go like either reshoot something or
do something a different way or
something and the plotting doesn't work
it's like literally built into the
budget so you're saying that that might
have contributed to not seeing kingo i'm
just saying we're just pop you know
possibly we're throwing it out there
we're throwing it out i don't know this
for truth in any way shape or form but
it felt so
like knee-jerk and so instant for a
character that we were really invested
in i'm not saying it didn't make sense
it didn't it made sense for the
character it made sense for the moment
it just seemed
like he kind of got the short shift in
the big battle and i don't think that's
the way i would have wanted to see it
but and also yeah he's he's also one of
the most popular characters if you're
actually watching this movie just right
you're you're his his humor and in his
powers he's one of the only guys that
can go peel pew right he actually has
like the big guns um
i was actually mad at him i was actually
mad at him for leaving and so when we
get to the ending and then you know um
they kind of have their little reunion
and he was hanging out on the sidelines
i was pissed at him like i was like wait
you guys are still friends after you
just sat it out on the sidelines when
you could have really helped like if
that was one of my homies i that would
change my friendship with that person
fundamentally quite honestly yeah yeah
so i don't think that
you know maybe there's more to be
explored but it just seemed like things
were back to normal oh we understand how
you felt i would have been pissed about
that i think a family member there would
have been some beef and some issues that
you would have had to resolve if someone
just stepped out on you during the
biggest moment of your quote-unquote
collective lives so
it actually pissed me off and i get it
but and maybe that's what chloe wanted
to tap into some of us to feel different
about this character he wasn't a villain
but we were frustrated like
in that gray decision or him just saying
i want to be on the silence i hated that
but yeah it did pull something from me
that maybe i haven't experienced in how
i feel about a superhero
yeah it'll be interesting to see what
happens and maybe that's setting
something up bigger um for future
installments because you know we're now
sort of getting to the close of the
movie and that was sort of
the biggest aspect of this is the
eternals save the day but it looks like
there's going to be some repercussions
to their actions
um and all of them are sort of like
literally being like beamed off of earth
uh to go deal with the fact that they're
in trouble
and that sets up what ends up being the
thing that people talk about the most
which is the biggest post credit scene
and that is
where um harry styles shows up so the
first thing about it this is is this has
been rumored for a while which i did not
know actually i tried to stay away from
it i stayed away from him as rumors as
possible quite honestly yeah i did not
know that harry styles was rumored to be
in this until i was getting ready for
the press conference and i watched jimmy
fallon basically pull an ellen on poor
kitt harrington trying to get him to
talk about things he didn't want to talk
about what did you think i i will say
this because
this was something that actually got
wildly reported very quickly after the
premiere and i feel bad for folks that
did not get surprised by this when that
happened i literally pulled the leonardo
dicaprio and once upon a time in
hollywood i was like right here
that's him because like at first i
couldn't remember who he was i was like
that's him that's him that's him right
there right there
at first i was like oh it's harry styles
like i'm not a one directioner so i
literally was like oh the boy from
dunkirk
i'm like the only person who did that
but norah what did you think
listen i'm in the camp of i'm a massive
harry styles fan and a marvel fan so i'm
quite literally situated in the middle
of this um and it was wild it was
bonkers to me and it almost
you know there's those actors where it's
like you're seeing them they're acting
but you're like man that's harry styles
like it all it took me like a solid half
of that post credit scene to be like
okay he's not harry styles he's playing
this character who i do enjoy from the
comics i think he will do a very good
job but i very much was like i couldn't
wrap my head around the fact that he was
now
showing up in this scene um and yeah i
did like it was obviously like leaked
very early and a lot of people that were
on the internet definitely saw it before
they got to experience in the theater
which i was very bummed about but my
theater when i saw it at like my local
theater
everybody was freaking out so it was
like great that people still had that
reaction to it because i think it
deserved that monumental reaction that
you get from a post-credit scene in a
marvel movie
oh we were i mean yeah in the premiere
yeah we were lucky enough to go to
when that scene hit uh so first of all
it's set up with pip the troll who
i'm not gonna be mean but the cg on pip
the troll did not look very good
compared to what we've seen especially
when we've been treated to like josh
brolin as thanos i was like
and again i can't do what these amazing
artists do but it just didn't look as
clean and as good um pat oswald is
playing patrol he's doing all these
introductions in it at first my brain
was actually thinking like adam warlock
we're going to see adam warlock because
pip patrol
are like this in the comics and then all
sudden he says
starfire and i was like oh dude are we
gonna see arrows but i didn't even
connect that it was gonna be harry
styles
at the premiere um people that
maybe some people were friends that came
to go see the premiere there were loud
shrieks it was not like uh yeah
it was like
yeah and like where it got louder you
kind of actually couldn't hear a little
bit of the dialogue because people were
screaming their heads off yeah and it
was and
here's the other point that i want to
you know kind of touch upon when we get
to these post credits is like
harry styles that's a quite honestly a
genius casting for arrows okay but
i'm a little frustrated now where we're
starting to see these post-credit scenes
have more impact and more buzz versus
the movies you know we saw that you know
that everyone talked about
after the premiere and because it was
partially leaked fine but people weren't
time out you know everything i saw on
the internet wasn't about like oh
whether people liked or even disliked
eternals it was about harry styles is in
the mcu you know so that took a lot of
shine away from the actual movie you
know we've seen this we kind of know
black widow's going to go on but the end
credit scene of black widow that sets up
um the new black widow
that kind of took away from it venom
let there be carnage you arguably didn't
have to even see that entire movie and
the tease with spider-man becomes more
important and so i'm a little
i guess fresher or not i don't want to
say worried but i think it is a
something to bring up that
i don't like these crap and credit
scenes that become bigger or maybe
sometimes over shine the movie i'd
rather have post credit scenes that are
at least a little more connected to the
movie like shanghi
the post-credits scene
although big and implying what's
happening in phase four and the power of
these rings at least it's connected more
to the actual movie we saw whereas here
in eternals it's like hey
harry styles is coming the mcu oh he'll
help you find the internals but it
wasn't really rude in a plot point it
was really rooted more in shock value
and so
that's something i hope changes i love
the post credit scenes but damn i was a
little bummed about that quite honestly
i mean
venom i don't know about mcu but venom
definitely did that yes on this on this
side
i don't know nor what about you
yeah i kind of feel the same way where
it's like
now you just want to get to the
post-credits scene in a lot of cases um
and even just like people i've talked to
that aren't big mcu fans were like well
what about those post-credits scenes um
so it's kind of like so like brian said
it's like
it's almost like we want to jump past
the meat of the movie to get to what
we're getting next um and i think just
in particular with these
it was such a big casting thing where of
course that's gonna over shine i think
if harry styles breathes
on twitter
like
it it'll become like a thing like like
it's him
beyonce taylor swift yeah uh anytime
they do anything
it is legitimately like bts
so much of a thing but it didn't exactly
hurt the situation that a variety
reporter tweeted about it and the tweet
got almost 100 000 likes on twitter
within 24 hours and i think brian knows
what's up because i actually spotted him
in the comments
i thought it was it's it's wrong it is
look as journalists as people who are
covering this stuff we're explicitly
told not to reveal any anything
basically just like general thoughts you
can't just
hey i hope it helps them out in the
short term but that's not a good look
for them long term and i and even disney
pr people came out and wrote deliberate
statements targeting what had just
happened
and to me it's wrong to take that
enjoyment that moment from fans away
from fans who it really does spoil that
kind of like oh my god yes there are
people that follow the blogs but not
everyone does and yeah that's kind of
the joy of why we watch these movies
that i don't get
go ahead go ahead nora no i was just
gonna say like speaking of like if
you're not actively looking for an mcu
spoiler like that spoiled it for the
regular human that loves an mcu movie
because suddenly it was everywhere like
and other outlets reporting it because
it was tweeted by you know a variety
reporter reporter and that was like
thing like i had to have a full
conversation with our team and being
like we are not reporting this because i
don't want to spoil anybody else it
doesn't have to be um and i just as me
personally and you guys as well like i
can't even imagine leaving that and
thinking that would be something i would
want to share and need to share in that
moment um so yeah i really think like
again like i don't think harry being in
that movie hurt the movie but i think it
was absolutely wild that it wasn't if
you were spoiled you didn't get the
shock and awe from you know no man
it very much felt like a moonlight not
winning the oscars the way that you
could type of moment like it very much
felt like we robbed yes an entire
section of people the chance to have
that moment of oh and again everybody
needs their leo moment
you know
and looking towards the future you know
we've touched on a little bit of the
sequels but the producer of this film
who produced it alongside kevin feige
nate moore he also produced black
panther
he said you know
they're they would be like sort of going
into riches if they have a sequel to the
eternals um that you can enjoy it on its
own
but
i mean
i don't know do you guys think that that
they're gonna play more into phase four
going forward
um yeah i'm just curious what you guys
think this means for the future in the
mcu as far as the eternals is concerned
well i think if they they laid a lot of
foundation here for the mcu and the
cosmic universe they had to right part
part of why maybe some people weren't
into it is they had to basically like
take us from the grounds of this is a
new area that we're exploring and they
explained it in depth i mean look the
whole explanation of the celestials
creating the eternals and the deviants
that is not something that cloijal that
that's a marvel thing right we when we
watch that we know that is marvel saying
this is an important part that we have
to tell the audience
and chloe
i don't know how much of that quote
unquote aspect she directed but that is
straight up marvel storytelling so you
know i think that they lay all this
foundation
for us to be open to new things to be
open to the celestials to be open to
greater beings in the cosmic universe
and that there's this whole now
world that we have literally not touched
for 10 years
that is gonna be important moving
forward um whether it's part of phase
four maybe it's even pushing out into
phase five quite honestly um and what
that means with you know we know nick
fury's in space right now with the
scrolls um there there's a lot of little
and the guardians of galaxy and thor are
out there somewhere in the cosmos so
there's a lot of pieces to the puzzle
we've got other families like who knows
how the fantastic four plays into this
cosmos as well and other future
characters um eros is involved now he's
not someone who's earthbound he's
out in the galaxy as well so um
this what's the guy from um from the
loki series what's his name um
kang the
this was
this was important to show all of that
to set us up through whatever happens in
phase four and from all indications
ant-man and the wasp quantum mania is
going to kind of open really open up we
have spider-man and doctor strange
that's going to touch on the multiverse
but when we talk about space and time i
mean
that all roads lead to kang the
conqueror and ant-man and wasp so um
it's it's it's absolutely crucial yeah i
definitely have to agree with brian and
say like i would think phase five is
probably where we're looking right now
with like if there were was an eternals
too i would love to see these characters
even pop up in other things i mean i
know we talked about post-credits scenes
but like that could be a place where we
get a hint of where they are going
forward in a movie coming up in phase
four um so yeah i definitely think it's
either through eternals too
a sequel to this movie or seeing these
characters in other properties and other
movies i think will be crucial because
they've laid so much groundwork it would
be
it'd be sad if like the groundwork is
there and then all of a sudden they're
gone and we don't see them for a very
long time um so yeah i definitely think
it opened everything up for the mcu in
terms of the cosmos and being able to
pull new characters from marvel because
we've laid this groundwork so i'm
excited to see where they go
can we also mention about dane whitman's
character i mean he has an end credit
scene yeah that we didn't touch on
that's pretty dang crucial um where he
sees what we believe to maybe be the
ebony blade which is his kind of weapon
of choice now time has gone on and at
the time we you know right after this
thing uh right after the movie ended you
know i had known kind of who that voice
did you you guys read the articles of
who that voice was talking to him do you
right you guys know who that or do you
know or not or do you want me to say or
not say no i mean why would you not say
brian go ahead i don't know
so it's a spoiler talks there i guess it
is a square title well a lot of people
when they first heard the voice even
though the theater
my girlfriend said oh that was nick fury
and i'm like i don't think that was nick
fury and i heard other people saying
that was nick fury and my brain was like
okay that
that
who else in the mcu coming up could be
related to this so i basically asked
some of my friends in within marvel
they're like
okay we'll tell you you know you can
play 20 questions to figure out but the
fact that they teased mahershala ali as
blade talking over the shoulder of black
knight
that's craziness so because his movie
isn't even scheduled for 2022 yet we
haven't even seen it on the docket
so
to tease blade like that
that to me that was more exciting than
harry styles
i mean this is the thing you have to go
on a bit of an easter hunt to find that
out though yeah which makes it fun
though right it does make it fun but i
think that's why that one was not as
talked about and yeah but again like i
said it's hair styles dude like as much
as i and you and me and nora can get
excited about that
the one directioners will win
oh always
always i
media in general wasn't talking about
that post-sentence credit scene because
i honestly don't think they knew who it
was or what it was
i mean i didn't until i read the article
so me too
yeah so um you know that was crazy
rehearsal needs to do more voice work so
i can clock him easier
oswald said one word and i was like oh
wow that's not an awful lot exactly i've
listened to you narrate the goldbergs
for eight seasons dude i can find your
voice anywhere
um shout out to the goldbergs too which
is a very enjoyable show
that people don't watch you should i i'm
one of those people jacqueline sorry you
should watch it it's very 80 centric i
mean it's a little waspy but it's good i
know i love it i just you know we all
got so much time in the day i mean let's
be honest yeah it's on hulu though so if
you if you're if you're bored during the
break uh the only thing i'll add to this
when we look to the future this is what
i will say about the eternals
the one thing we have learned through
endgame through time
is the chapters on these movies are not
always written
the first time they come out
when we get to end game remember like
we all know what happened with josh
sweden and so i'm not gonna go too far
into him as a person but
he got very like
pressurized with
ultron because of everything that he had
to set up and we actually did an article
on rotten tomatoes breaking down how
that is like the linchpin of how they
were able to write the second half of
the first two chapters of the mcu that
first like 10
years
was held together by what they did in
ultron they set up wakanda they set up
the hulk's journey they set up um
you know ragnarok they set up all of
these things
that we then like bear that fruit
through the second half that you know
thanos and all of the stuff that we end
up dealing with later
all is very much set forth in ultron and
that was a movie that did not get a very
good reception people were not really
happy with it but looking back on it
you're like oh my god if we didn't have
all this stuff here yep how hard it
would have been go forward i have a
feeling eternals is gonna be this movie
yeah it's just gonna be this movie that
we look back on and be like oh
yeah like we wouldn't have been able to
get here without
chloe sort of biting the bullet and
maybe that's why she couldn't make the
movie that she really in every way
wanted to make because there were so
many demands because there's like a
checklist of things you kind of have to
get through
and if this is that movie and it still
makes the money and we still get to play
in here no one is going to care
and it's gonna and it'll be you know an
episode where you know people are coming
back and singing its praises just like
they did with ultron the story on ultron
completely shifted 10 years after or
five years after it came out so yeah i
predict that that will probably happen
with this one as well and i think that
is a great place to leave it nora and
brian i want to thank you both again
this was such a fun chat um i'm sure i
will see you both
back with us as soon as possible to talk
something but nora starting with you
tell us what you're working on and where
folks can find you
yeah so um tv editor over at buzzfeed um
also cover most of our marvel stuff so
we're getting into a wild time i do like
our easter eggs posts and details posts
in terms of marvel stuff
that's a fun easter egg hunt always um
so yeah i'm over there you can check me
out there pretty active on twitter as
well a lot of live tweeting shows and
stuff like that so yeah awesome and
brian same question um for everyone
that's watching i do a lot of tech and
geek culture coverage so everything from
apple samsung google but i also get some
cool access kind of behind the scenes of
what happens with some of these movies
so uh coming around november 12th we
know that shanghai is going to stream on
disney plus so i have a piece with the
lead visual concept artist andy park of
how they came up with the costumes what
things did marvel tell them they needed
to involve in character design like
abomination actual shang qi
and all the cast so just kind of a
really fun exploration talking about if
you're into that nitty gritty stuff
which i know a lot of you are um
how those designs and character designs
came to be and
so you can check it out when it comes
out all righty then well again thank you
all for watching i want to thank ed
disilla behind the scenes as well all of
you guys for watching we will see you
guys next time with our next episode of
the after show
[Music]
you